welcome home thank you my second home is
that could help yeah how much time to
we're in Toronto's famous graffiti and
yes yeah this is where you've recorded
most of the rants that you done for this
job ninety-eight percent have been in
this valley the media will always tell
us that kids today are entitled on that
point I will agree they are entitled to
a better country and a better world and
from what I've seen this generation
they're gonna make that happen 15
seasons yeah are you gonna watch the
final episode oh for sure yeah
I always watch the show at least one eye
on the show because when I see it on TV
with the commercials I know it's real
right and I've never gotten tired of
being on TV it's what I always wanted
and I get a kick out of it yeah yeah
does it has it ever become tire ring did
you have a tire of that as a creative
person that's a very long time I'd be
doing something similar I've been tired
but I don't find it tiring you've been
in this position before will you see
somebody on a great television show
seems like they have a great life and
they're walking away and you're like
what are you doing oh I know what do you
do this is what the guy at the airport
said he had my he had my boarding pass
this is a Newfoundland he said you're
leaving the show I said yeah he said
biggest mistake of your life and like
that loud yeah and I was like uh-huh
well and then he turned to like the
woman behind me he's like yes isn't it
and she's kind of going yeah yeah so why
why because you know this in television
in media in radio usually things come to
an end when you show up and your
possessions are in a box out by the door
right and there's a format change we're
country-western now or whatever and
that's the way you change careers in
show business and I want it to be one of
those shows that went out on my own
terms and I didn't want to be guilty of
sticking around too long do you have a
favorite do you have a favorite person
who you got to a layer and showed the
people of this country something that
they have never seen well I wouldn't say
he's a favorite politician but certainly
I remember shooting with Stephen Harper
and and I found it very curious it's one
of the few times he allowed people to
show that he
actually had a sense of humor you know
when I can't sleep I count ridings
Fabray of course I show that he was the
kind of guy who would get naked and jump
in a lake right but that says you know
what that says something about a person
that's what it was important the feeling
that you get from this show what do you
replace that with now right I don't know
I think can you replace it with I
honestly don't know it you know as you
may know that sometimes in the past
performers that have a stage when that
stage is removed yes they go a little
funny yeah I don't think I'm gonna be
that guy like in the backyard ranting
over the fence at the neighbors I don't
think I'm gonna be that guy but I don't
know what I do that I am genuinely so
happy that I've got to do this for 15
years and I love the fact that wherever
I go in the country people are genuinely
happy to see me like no one really takes
a swing at me and when I started doing
this because people knew me from TV if I
saw a kid on the street somewhere they'd
say like hey you're the guy from TV what
are you doing here like that's what kids
say about wherever they live we do it
here and then about two years in we were
in the Scent central of center of
British Columbia somewhere northern
British Columbia and in a small town and
this kid said hey I knew you'd show up
eventually huh and I you know the bell
went off and I thought huh people are
getting this is getting this is my beat
and I loved every minute of it
[Music]